I'm gonna ask you a question what would
happen if the earth was a cube or if it
wasn't but what what happened if it was
what the gravity we wear or the same
thank you for answering my question that
is a great question
and I can give you a real science answer
the earth is not a cube because it has
enough stuff it has enough rocks and
metals and water and lava and everything
that all pull on each other equally and
this every time you do that you get a
ball you get a sphere in other words if
you made a cubical earth and it was
orbiting the Sun and so on after a few
years
pick a number a few million years it
would squish itself into a ball and so
when we study asteroids we go out there
with spacecraft and look at asteroids
dawn Vesta Hayabusa 2 we observe
asteroids that are not cubes but are
very rough they're very they have
irregular shapes they're not they're not
balls they're not they don't have enough
stuff to become balls or spheres but you
are alive when the first pictures from
Pluto came back to Earth and Pluto is
apparently right there at the having
just enough stuff to make it into a ball
it's cool so it's because everything's
pushing and the same thing in the same
direction all the time on everything
else it resolves itself or it ends up as
a ball try this get some marbles and a
big rubber band and put the marble on a
tabletop put the marbles in the rubber
band and just kind of wiggle it around
you'll see it'll become a circle it will
not if you try to make it into a square
the rubber band will blink will burn
slowly bring it all back into a circle
and so a planet becoming a ball is like
the rubber band and the marbles but all
in three dimensions instead of two in a
ball instead of just a circle a circle
rotated through a circle it's a cool
question so the reason planets are
spheres or balls is because they have
enough gravity pulling all in this
pulling all the stuff together at the
same time that there you end up with no
sharp edges no irregular bumps three
it's cool
except us in outer space there's no
sound it just goes